in this place
we are approximately five thousand women
1,250 of us suffered or will suffer
at some point in their lives a sexual attack
one in four
only 10 percent base the complaint
the remaining 90 percent take refuge
in silence
one half because  the event occurs
within the family or with someone they
know and that makes it much more difficult
to live and tell the other half do not
speak because they fear that they will
not be believed and they are right because we do not believe them
today I want to tell you because I think
that we don't believe them we
don't believe her because when a woman
tells what happened to her she says things that
we can't imagine that disturb us that we don't
expect to hear that amaze
us we expect to hear stories
like these young woman raped on the
miter railroad tracks it happened at
midnight  When she was returning home,
the young woman said that a subject assaulted
from behind told her not to shout
that he had a weapon and to stay
still, he raped her and then  used when
we hear or read news like
this we are immediately presented with an
image
the
rapist a low-class pervert
the victim an attractive young woman the
image lasts no more than 10 or 20 seconds and
is dark it is flat there are no movements there
are no sounds it is like  if there were no
people but when a woman
tells what happened to
her her story would not fit 10 or 20 seconds
the following is the testimony of a
woman we are going to call ana one
of the 85 women that i
interviewed during a  research I
did on rape says ana
we had gone with the girls from the
office to the same dad we go to we always
met some kids and I hooked up
with a skinny guy she received we talked a
lot
about it at around 4 o'clock I told my friends
no  let's go they wanted to stay
so the skinny man asked me where he
lived and told me that if it seemed good to
me he would approach me accept and we didn't go at a
traffic light he told me he liked me and
touched my leg
I don't like it and a guy advances like that
but he had been loving all night
I thought I can't be so paranoid that's why
I say something to him and the guy had nothing to do with it and I
offend him when he had to turn he went on by
I thought he had made a mistake and  I told him
you went too far but I felt something ugly now
I think why didn't he pay attention to what
I felt when he stopped the car near
the highway
there I was scared but he told me to
stay calm that he liked me and
that nothing was going to happen if  I didn't want
anything good
I said nothing to him because I was afraid
he would get angry and everything got worse
I thought he might have a gun in the
glove compartment suddenly he threw himself on
me and wanted to kiss me
I told him I didn't want to push him but he
had me  arms when I let go I tried
to open the door but it was stuck the
same if I got out of the car where I
was going I told him that he was not the kind of guy
who needs to do that to be with
a girl that I also liked but he
didn't try that way  to calm him down
she said nice things about him she spoke to him as
if I were her older sister suddenly
she covered my mouth with one hand and with the
other she unbuckled her belt
at that moment I thought she could kill me
hang me you know I never felt so alone
as kidnapped
I asked her  that it will end quickly and I will take
my house what happened to them listening to this
story surely
several questions disappeared for example why he did not
lower the window and ask for help
because he did not get out of the car when he
sensed that something ugly could happen how
could he ask the series to the  home
now when we are not facing
news in the media or facing a
story that a person like me is
telling you from a stage like this
when we are facing someone we
know and who chose us to
trust us with their story what happened to them
we are going to  having to listen to it we were going to
listen to things that we are not going to be able to
understand
or accept so
doubts, questions and suspicions will not appear and that is going
to make us feel  going very bad guilty
then to defend ourselves from that
discomfort we have a resource we turn
up the volume on all those things in
the story that we expected to hear the
revolver in the glove compartment the
locked doors the isolation of the place and we turn
down the volume on all those things
that  we did not expect to hear and that we
do not want to hear, for example
when she tells him that she liked him too
or when she tells us that she spoke to him
as if she were her older sister or
that she asked him to take her
home what is the point of doing this to create him
to be able to trust that she really
was a victim
I call this victimization of
victims victimization because in order to
believe that she is innocent and that she is a
victim we
need to think of the helpless
paralyzed mute
but there is another way to get rid of
the discomfort and that is exactly  the
inverse we turn up the volume to the
things that we did not expect to hear as
I spoke to him well I asked him to take
me  house I asked him to finish quickly
and we lowered it to the things that yes but we are going
to listen to the revolver in the glove compartment the
insulation
this is so that it is
useful so that we can grasp the
doubts and feel more comfortable with the
doubts
then new questions appear
for  For example, who sent her to go to those
bowling alleys?
You saw how she dresses and her
friends don't minise them. The necklines that
Pedráz asked questions that are not really
questions or rather trials and trials
that end in a sentence.
corroborated by the fact that she
later did not say that she had fought to
avoid the rape,
so it means that she did not resist, it
means that she consented if she was
asked for it and she consented that rape speaks to me, she
called this blaming the
victims, both the arguments that
serve us  to blame as to
victimize we all have them all in our
heads very close at hand, including victims and
victimizers,
so much so that when  o Ana came to
me and told me that she didn't know if her testimony
was going to help me because she wasn't
sure that what had happened to her
had been a rape
Ana, like most of
us, also believed that rape
is more like  to an armed robbery a
violent procedure that lasts 45 minutes and
not the chamuyo of a nice young man
that lasts all night and that ends
a kidnapping when she was afraid that they would
kill her she was afraid that they would leave
marks on her and had to hand over her  body
to avoid it
there she knew that the rape was something else
ana had never talked about it with
anyone she could have turned to the
family but she did
n't she didn't because she was afraid she was
afraid that the person she had
chosen to tell her about would be  The same thing will happen
that happens to all of us and that is that
doubts and suspicions arise
every time
a topic like this is discussed
and if that had happened it would have been
perhaps worse than the rape itself could
have  To speak with a friend with a
sister very difficultly with the couple
the slightest hint of doubt on her face in
her voice
would have been devastating for her and
probably the end of the relationship is
not kept silent because
intimately she knows that no one not all of
us nor  Her family nor the therapists,
much less the police or the magistrates,
are willing to listen to what Ana
did at that moment. First and
foremost, Ana said no when she saw that her work
was not useless,
I spoke well to her, I tried not to exacerbate her
violence, not to give her ideas  He spoke to him
as if everything that was happening at
that moment had been normal
so as not to arouse fear in him that
later he could report it now I
ask myself and I ask them all that he
did that is not resisting
no it is not for all of us or  almost
all of us probably because
it is not for the law
in most countries the codes
continue to ask the victim to
prove his innocence
I mean the victim  To prove her
innocence, she presented marks on her
body to witnesses in which she had a
tenacious and constant fight with her aggressor.
I can assure you that in
most judicial cases there are no marks
that reach.
I listened to many women and I did not listen.
I didn't talk about herself as if she
had been reduced to something
completely subject to the will of the
other.
Rather, I listened to them as if astonished and
even a little proud to recognize
the lucid ones who had been
attentive to every detail at this moment,
as if  that will allow them to have some
control over what was happening,
so I thought of course what
women do in these situations is to
negotiate, they negotiate sex for life, they ask
the aggressor to finish quickly so that
all that is finished as soon as possible with
the lowest cost.  they submit to
penetration because although they cannot
create it, penetration is what
keeps them farthest from a sexual
or affective scene, they submit to  penetration
because penetration hurts less
than kisses caresses soft words
now we are going to continue hoping
that rapes are what very rarely
are a rapist who is a
low-class pervert and not a young university student or
a businessman who comes out of  get up on a
friday or a saturday
if we're going to keep expecting the
victims to be demure dating women
who faint at the scene and
not self-assured women
we're still going to be unable to listen
women are going to continue to be unable to speak and
we're going to continue  everyone being responsible
for that silence and their loneliness
[Applause]